in weißwasser in sachsen begrüße ich
jetzt timo cooper sd bundessprecher und
fraktionsvorsitzender der afc
bundestagsfraktion grüße sie herr kubala
ich grüße sie hallo wie bewerten sie den
jetzt vorliegenden koalitionsvertrag
der insgesamt muss man für deutschland
konstatiert es kommen wirklich schwere
zeiten auf deutschland entfallen auch
die bürger zu ist wenn nicht mehr
staatliche eingriffe erfolgen weitere
unterfallen mehr finanzielle belastungen
damit weniger freiheit wie die bürger
gehen also von einer regierung der mitte
zu sprechen ist wirklich viel was herr
nehmen da hier auch gesagt hat wir haben
einen klaren linksruck in diesem bereich
wir sehen auch dass sich ein staat umbau
stattfindet noch mehr zentralisierung
richtung eu also wir geben immer mehr
souveränität aufpreis wird immerhin rede
zum beispiel von mindestquoten in der
beschaffung was ein stück weit ein
sozialistische planspiele erinnert wenn
ich aufhöre insgesamt heißt es ist ja
mehr fortschritt wagen das erinnert
nicht so an einen drei oder fünf jahres
plan der sed in der ddr man muss
natürlich sie jetzt in vielem begründung
in diesem koalitionsvertrag drin wie sie
umsetzen lassen und noch mal wie
wirklich dahin wäre das alles bezahlen
und es wird die mittelstädte mittelstand
sein dass auch bezahlen betragen das
haben sie viele punkte genannt was ist
für sie der wichtigste punkt in der
kritik
also zum beispiel wenn ich als beispiel
neben den kohleausstieg wenn wir zu den
hehren klimazielen dieser neuen
bundesregierung kommen dieser kollege
war schon mit vertraglich gesichert bis
2038 als ein beispiel also man hält sich
hier auch nicht mehr an verträge gerade
für die ostdeutschen mitteldeutschen
revier in die regionen ist es wirklich
sehr schwierig in 38 als ableiten schon
einzuhalten haben ja immer alles auf die
gesagt wir 45 er ist schon schwer
durchführbar jetzt hat man es nochmal
vorverlegt auf das jahr 2030 das wird
für die region wirklich mit massiven
sozialen problemen einher gehen aber
auch mit vielen arbeitsplatzverlust aber
auch mit der strom sicherheit der
netzsicherheit wenn ja erklärt niemals
wie man hier auch neue energieträger
dazu führen wird die energiesicherheit
gewährleisten will man spricht zwar von
der errichtung von gaskraftwerken
aber gleichwohl setzt man zb nord stream
2 wieder in frage als da muss man ja
auch erklären können guttenberg das gas
her kommt dass die gaskraftwerke
benötigen und in 89 jahren noch dazu
beim aktuellen planungsstand kann man
aktuell keine gaskraftwerke bauen also
dass da müsste man hätte man schon
längst anfahren müssen auch also ja auch
die bundesregierung geschlafen und das
lässt sich leider fort das heißt sie
sagen da macht man in vielen dingen den
zweiten schritt vor dem ersten weil man
auch die finanzierung und auch ein
zeitlich vernünftigen fahrplan nicht
realisiert hat ist dass der schwerpunkt
auch ihre kritik verstehe ich sie
richtig
absolut feiern wenn man jetzt verträge
geschlossen hat nochmal auch in der
vergangenheit dann muss man diese auch
einhalten die unternehmen der
mittelstand braucht planungssicherheit
und das hat mittlerweile ja das kleine
schritt corona nicht mehr also die
unternehmen sind jetzt schon völlig
demoralisiert in einer tiefen depression
jetzt kommt noch diese regierungs wie
der regierungsvertrag dazu wer wirklich
hier mehr immer mehr auch auf
transformationen setzt das wort kann
formationen kommen wir auch in diesem
koalitionsvertrag vor aber auch hier am
willen der bürger vorbei hier muss man
wirklich mehr mitsprache auch den
bürgern aber auch der kommunen vor ort
einrollen und das sehe ich in diesem
koalitionsvertrag nicht sprechen
abschließend noch über den künftigen
bundeskanzler mutmaßliche olaf scholz
was glauben sie wie wird er seine
regierung machen beziehungsweise wenn
sie sein berater während was für einen
tipp würden sie eben geben wo er noch
nachholen müsste
insgesamt hat attila olaf scholz die
ersten 100 tage zeit seine regierung
erst mal dementsprechend auszustellen
wir wissen ja noch nicht wie tieres soll
die gerichtsurteile und wissen wir aber
welche minister diese besetzen das gilt
es abzuwarten ich hoffe dass er mehr auf
seine bürger her dass er mehr auf die
bürger eingeht auf die interessen der
bürger ich habe aber da auch schon
wieder vernommen gerade was in der
korona krise hier gesagt dass hier ein
expertengremium im bundeskanzleramt
angesiedelt werden soll also wie geht
eigentlich schon wieder die kugel
wirtschaft weiter die wir immer
kritisiert dieser expertenrat gehört in
das parlament in den bundestag mit allen
gremien aber auch zum beispiel mit
stimmen der wirtschaft die auch dort
gerne einfluss nehmen können auch dort
die beratungsstellen haben also hier
sollte wird wird wieder was versucht am
parlament vorbei zu setzen und das
kritisieren wir hier muss es ganz klare
prioritäten geben ins parlament hinein
woche die entscheidung getroffen wenn
ich hoffe dass er das auch umsetzt
meinungen und einschätzungen waren das
von timo kfd bundessprecher und
fraktionsvorsitzender der
bundestagsfraktion
ich danke für das gespräch wünsche ihnen
einen schönen tag in weißensee in
sachsen
gegangen danke auch